[Music]
kimmy schmitt your character you have to
smile all yeah you smile constantly in
the role we have a picture of you in the
role and you are and I was thinking I
was thinking it's gotta be hard to smile
all that yeah I think that is hard I
think I think two things and you might
have a similar problem cuz you smile a
lot when I'm not smiling
people think I'm furious and I have
noticed that the more I smile the deeper
the wrinkles in my face get and I'm a
woman and I don't love wrinkles so when
I try not when I try to rest my face
which is just me like talking to someone
and just right just like that people
think I'm furious I don't I'm gonna show
it let's see your this is called resting
[ __ ]
you think you have resting [ __ ]
yeah that look that's mad thinking yeah
I can relate because people are used to
seeing me like hey everybody and then
when I just walk around and I'm neutral
I call it just neutral if I'm neutral
it looks like I'm constipated and sad
and it's just I mean this is me just
driving home like this
[Applause]
keep the camera there this is me driving
home on the 405 freeway at night people
pull up and I have clear windows and
they see like I think that's gonna Brian
and I go like this probably like I saw
him he's real
so strong with him just me you're
listening to the radio you're trying to
rest your face yeah I understand I'm not
trying to do anything
oh that's just me driving a car what the
solution is cuz you can't just I one
weekend recently Michael was out of town
and I really didn't talk to your husband
Michael he used to write for us yes the
week one now he's stopped
I'm kidding his legs are weak but a
strong writer when he chose to write he
was out of town I didn't really talk to
anyone that weekend and I realized oh I
haven't really been like making any
facial expressions ie merged Monday
morning like a newborn babe like I might
just lines on my face like they were
gone yeah I think cuz like cuz well
anyway you have to have these cuz like
if you're making facial expressions you
have to act but I have these deep
grooves in my face just no but I do fool
my father is somewhat inscrutable he
does not make a lot of expressions he is
in his 60s he does not have a line on
his face and I think it pays off right
from a lifetime of just like right
expressing anything right and I'm in
trouble cuz my whole my feels like a
great deal yeah yeah lose skin for a
joyless light yeah
you tell me that's the Rob Lowe secret
so you do it never enjoyed a moment of
his life yeah yeah perfect skill
you